digamos que hemos ideado una nueva
píldora que creemos que tiene una buena
posibilidad de ayudar a las personas con
diabetes a controlar su nivel de azúcar
en la sangre cuando alguien tiene
diabetes sus niveles de azúcar en la
sangre son inusualmente altos y eso daña
a su cuerpo de diferentes maneras así
que queremos llevar a cabo un
experimento para probar si esta píldora
realmente puede ayudar a las personas a
bajar el azúcar en la sangre de modo que
lo primero que tenemos que pensar es
cómo vamos a medir o probar si el azúcar
en la sangre de las personas está
disminuyendo bueno para nuestro
experimento lo que generalmente se hace
es medir la hemoglobina a1c de las
personas no tienes que preocuparte mucho
sobre esto en el contexto de la
estadística pero la prueba de
hemoglobina a1c es la forma que se usa
normalmente para medir el nivel promedio
de azúcar en la sangre durante los
últimos tres meses y tenemos vídeos
completos en khan academy que explican
cómo funciona por lo tanto nuestra
esperanza sería que nuestra píldora
era el azúcar en la sangre de las
personas lo cual aparecería como un aún
no se ha reducido
ahora tenemos términos para esto
llamamos variable explicativa a lo que
está causando que algo cambie variable
explicativa y lo que podría cambiar con
esa variable explicativa dependiendo de
si toma la píldora o no lo llamamos
nuestra respuesta variable de respuesta
así que ahora vamos a llevar a cabo el
experimento entonces lo que haríamos es
ir a la población
población de diabéticos
y nos gustaría tomar una muestra
aleatoria de esa población de diabéticos
una muestra razonablemente grande y más
adelante en estadística hablaremos de lo
que podría ser una muestra de buen
tamaño pero digamos que muestra mos 100
personas al azar tomamos una muestra
aleatoria de 100 personas de esa
población de diabéticos y luego
quisiéramos asignar las aleatoriamente a
dos grupos diferentes uno sería el grupo
de control y este sería el grupo de
personas que no van a tomar el nuevo
medicamento y luego tendríamos el grupo
de tratamiento este sería el grupo de
personas que recibirían el nuevo
medicamento el grupo de tratamiento
ahora en algunos casos se pueden asignar
aleatoriamente estas 100 personas entre
estos dos grupos y una forma de hacerlo
es darles a todos un número aleatorio
entre 1 y 100 y luego los 50 primeros
ingresan al grupo de tratamiento y los
otros 50 al de control o podemos usar
una computadora para asignar personas al
azar pero algunas veces vamos a querer
ser
más sofisticados por ejemplo podría
haber evidencia de que el sexo podría
influir de alguna manera en como
responde a alguien a un medicamento
entonces lo que podríamos hacer es algo
llamado diseño de bloques donde digamos
este grupo tiene 60 mujeres y 40 hombres
en un diseño de bloque podemos asignar
aleatoriamente pero podemos hacerlo de
manera de que estemos seguros de que
ambos grupos tengan las mismas
proporciones de hombres y mujeres por
ejemplo si tenemos 60 mujeres aquí
podemos asegurarnos de que 30 de ellas
terminen en el grupo de control y 30 en
el de tratamiento pero asignaremos esas
60 mujeres aleatoriamente entre estos
dos grupos y de la misma manera podemos
hacer el diseño de bloques de estos 40
hombres 20 terminarían en el grupo de
control y 20 en el de tratamiento
entonces una vez que tengamos personas
en estos dos grupos lo que probablemente
quisiéramos hacer es medir su aún no sé
al principio podemos ver eso como una
línea de base
y luego a lo largo del experimento le
daríamos la píldora al grupo de
tratamiento y simplemente no haríamos
nada en el grupo de control
pero en realidad la mejor práctica es
darle al grupo de control una píldora
que se vea como algo real esto se conoce
como un placebo y la razón por la que lo
hacemos es porque definitivamente hay
evidencia de que cuando las personas
piensan que están tomando una píldora
que podría ayudarles
incluso psicológicamente puede tener un
efecto sobre ellas y algunas veces les
ayuda esto se conoce como efecto placebo
y no solo le daríamos una píldora que
tiene el mismo aspecto a los dos grupos
a pesar de que la píldora del grupo de
tratamiento realmente tiene el
medicamento también quisiéramos
ocultarle a la gente en que el grupo
está cuando no se les dicen que el grupo
están se le conoce como un experimento
ciego y probablemente tampoco queramos
decirles a las personas que administran
el experimento a qué grupo están
administrando y a eso se le llama doble
ciego entonces incluso los médicos a las
enfermeras
que administran el experimento cuando
administran una píldora al grupo de
control no sabrían que esa píldora es el
placebo y podrías decir bueno porque es
importante que un experimento sea ciego
o especialmente de doble ciego pues por
un lado eso evita cualquier tipo de
efecto psicológico de parte del paciente
por otro desde el punto de vista de los
cuidadores en esta situación para que no
revelen en qué grupo están para que no
le digan a las personas que en realidad
solo están fingiendo tomar una píldora y
eso asegura que minimicemos la cantidad
de influencia o sesgo que pudiera
ocurrir o podríamos tener un experimento
triple ciego en el que incluso las
personas que están analizando los datos
finales de este experimento no saben si
están analizando los datos del grupo de
control o del de tratamiento simplemente
comparan los dos grupos pero de
cualquier manera la gente toma el
medicamento o el placebo en el
transcurso del experimento tal vez esto
dure tres meses y luego quisiéramos
medirse a uno se ver
ahora si viéramos que en realidad no
hubo una diferencia en el cambio de a1c
entre el grupo de control y el grupo de
tratamiento entonces diríamos bueno eso
probablemente significa que la píldora
no funcionó ahora si obtenemos una mayor
reducción en el grupo de tratamiento y
llevamos a cabo el análisis estadístico
que aprenderemos en estadística y
demostramos que hay una probabilidad muy
baja de que esto ocurra simplemente por
casualidad entonces tenemos algo
probablemente podríamos concluir que
existe una conexión causal entre tomar
la píldora y bajar el nivel de a1c pero
una vez más no podemos estar 100%
seguros y por eso es muy importante que
otras personas puedan replicar el
experimento porque lo que quisiéramos es
que nosotros mismos u otros
investigadores realicen el experimento
con diferentes tamaños de muestra
diferentes países y diferentes
poblaciones tal vez con diferentes
edades en diferentes épocas del año para
garantizar que se continúe viendo este
resultado
hasta el próximo vídeo